hey guys it's justine and i kind of saw
this news today
or it's been rumored for quite a while
that apple is going to be announcing a
mixed
reality headset and i'm checking out
right here on mac rumors they're saying
that they're actually
set to announce this in the next couple
of months adden
hold on in person event
i am just as shook and shocked as you
are i do feel like at some point we are
going to have to kind of test the waters
of what do
in-person events look like and i think
if anybody is going to be able to test
this out and figure out a really good
model
or even when you get to the event you
have to do some sort of rapid covered
test
to even enter i'm not really sure but
it's going to be really interesting to
see kind of how this whole new world
sort of evolves
out of what this last year has presented
us but me
as someone who sometimes does gets a
little motion sickness
in vr it's unfortunate because i love it
so much and i think that's why i kind of
like
augmented reality because i'm not kind
of enclosed inside of a headset
i don't feel so constricted and a lot of
the headsets
they're not uncomfortable especially
with like the quest headsets
they're actually very comfortable if you
guys remember not too long ago
these types of headsets you had to be
connected to a piece
there were cables it was heavy sometimes
you'd have to wear a backpack with
limited battery power
so now kind of bringing this to the
masses
like oculus has done is kind of exciting
and i know obviously there's been a lot
of drama with oculus because of facebook
needing to authenticate it's going to be
interesting how apple kind of handles
this obviously with a lot of the new
privacy policies in the app store with
their nutrition labels
i know that also stemmed a lot of drama
from a lot of devs because
they didn't really want to disclose all
of the information that they have been
gathering from us so
i do very much appreciate knowing how
much information is actually
given out to people but in this article
it's saying that bloomberg had
previously reported that apple's first
ar vr headset
would be a high-end pricey and niche
device aimed at developers
internally apple believes it could sell
just one headset per day at its retail
locations
180 units a year at its 500 stores
i mean math headset is rumored to have
dual 8k
displays eye tracking and more than a
dozen cameras for tracking hand
movements which is going to be kind of
cool
and one of the things that i really did
like about the quest is when you kind of
turned on
i don't know what they call it exactly
but it's like the mode where you can
kind of see
around you i think apple's going to
hopefully
do a lot kind of in sort of that vein
because they've been pushing augmented
reality
so much over the past couple of and i
think that
really with whatever this headset is if
it's small if it's a pair of wearable
glasses
that's gonna be the future it really is
i just don't think that they're gonna be
able to make it
that significantly smaller than the
oculus quest especially if they plan on
packing all of this tech inside of it
one thing that kind of sparked my
interest though
with this article is because wwdc is
coming up they officially announced that
it's happening july 7th through 11th
and it's gonna be all digital all
virtual but this is kind of where
developers we get a sense of what the
next few years
are gonna look like with apple so it
would make sense that they
pre-announced this just to let us all
know that this is something that is in
the works
and get these headsets to developers
immediately because without having
developers developing specifically for
this type of headset it's going to be
really difficult to even want to own it
without having content i mean even
oculus yes there's a lot of content but
there's still
i don't think is enough for like the
mass audience of people to be like this
is something that i need to have in my
house we're gonna be using it every day
there's enough content here that i can
basically live inside of vr ar
it's not quite there and i think that's
okay i think we are a few years away
from this
kind of a staple of a household where
everybody does have something in their
home like this
getting this out now potentially in june
is gonna be amazing did i say july or
did i say june last year they kind of
had to scramble and get this all
together whereas now
they've had a full year to plan and know
this is gonna be digital only
i would love to hear from you guys
though in the comments like what are you
expecting i feel like initially when we
first started seeing these headset
kind of rumors we were all sort of
picturing some sort of like google glass
type thing which i really loved google
glass like
i thought it was cool a kind of small
little heads up display
and you could kind of just integrate it
into your everyday life i'm still
holding out for something like that from
apple but i do think them
kind of taking this leap into the vr ar
space with a headset
like something similar to oculus quest
is exciting so
i know i'll be looking out for it what
about you i'll see you guys my next
video
don't forget to subscribe like this
video if you enjoyed it and leave a
comment below so that i can
chat with you guys in the comments